tengo una función definida por pedazos y
mi objetivo es determinar su dominio y
su rango así que fijémonos primero en su
dominio y recordemos que el dominio de
una función es el conjunto de valores de
entrada en los que la función está
definida en este caso nuestros valores
de entrada están representados por la
letra x muy bien así que fijémonos en
eso la función toma el valor 1 cuando x
es mayor que 0 y menor o igual que 2 y
puede tomar el valor 5 cuando x es mayor
que 2 y menor que 6 o bien puede tomar
el valor menos siete cuando x es mayor o
igual que 6 o menor o igual que 11 así
que aquí no se está dando justamente los
valores posibles en los que la función
está definida justamente para valores
por ejemplo menores que 0 para valores
menores o incluso el 0 no está definido
verdad aquí está definido para x
estrictamente mayor que 0 entonces para
pero hacia atrás es decir todos los
negativos y 0 no tenemos una forma de
asignarles un valor verdad a esos
valores de x y tampoco tenemos para
números mayores que 11 así que nuestro
dominio son son aquellos números que son
mayores que 0 por ejemplo lo que
corresponde a esto verdad son aquellos
números x mayores que 0 y por ejemplo
hasta el 2 está definido luego saltamos
a este pedazo desde 2 hasta 6 ahí está
bien definido y luego está definido de 6
a 11 todo está muy bien definido desde 0
hasta 11 verdad que esa parte
corresponde a esta otra verdad todos
estos valores está definido el dominio
entonces podríamos incluso escribirlo
así todos
el dominio es son todos los números
reales números reales tales que tales
que satisfacen que están entre 0 y 11
incluyendo el 11 y excluyendo el 0 ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa con el rango y este
es algo muy sencillo para esta función
porque el rango son todos los valores
posibles que una función puede tomar
verdad así que esto es muy simple esta
función sólo puede tomar tres valores
posibles 1 5 y menos 7 así que una forma
de describir el rango podría ser que la
función evaluado en cualquier punto solo
puede cada caer en este conjunto de
verdad sólo puede ser un elemento esto
es este es el símbolo digamos matemático
que usamos para decir que es un elemento
de este conjunto que sólo tiene tres
posibilidades 1 5 y menos 7 y esta es
digamos una forma muy elegante muy
matemática de escribir que la función
sola solo toma valores en este
o bien podríamos decir que fx es igual a
-7 pero esto quizás es una forma no muy
precisa de representar lo anterior el
punto es que esta función sólo puede
tomar uno de esos tres valores